i think the united states has been
fighting far too much and we've got to
choose another path
135 countries at least
where the united states has gone to war
do you think we could have avoided all
the wars that we had the united states
is not safer and the world is not safer
because there are 750 bases around the
world why do you think we're in so many
different places the bush administration
did not need to respond to that those
crimes with war the vast majority of
people in afghanistan had no
responsibility for the attacks of 9 11.
you attacked our land
and you want me to sit there and not do
anything about it by giving them the war
they wanted that was an achievement for
them isis is a product of the us war in
iraq we created isis aren't we in too
deep to play nice now
[Music]
my guest today is a professor at
american university and he recently
wrote a book called the united states of
war a global history of america's
endless conflict from columbus to the
islamic state david thank you so much
for being a guest on valuetainment
patrick i'm really thrilled i'm excited
for the conversation yes i i am probably
more excited than you are because this
is something that i want to
uh take a deep dive on so david for
viewers who don't know your background i
mean there's a lot of things you can
write a book about you can write a book
about pokemon cards you can write a book
about you know who's the greatest
basketball player of all time you can
buy it write a you know book on you know
caviar studying the history of caviar
what inspired you to want to write a
book on the united states of war a
global history of america's endless
conflicts from columbus to islamic state
in short i think we have to stop
fighting
i think the united states has been
fighting far too much
for far too long and we've gotta
choose another path
uh you know more than a quarter of the
country now has no memory of a time when
the united states was not at war
more than a quarter of the country
cannot remember a day in their lives
when the united states was not at war
we've been a war for 20 consecutive
years since the us invaded afghanistan
in 2001.
and when i began research for this book
i thought this was
fairly exceptional in u.s history and i
came to find that actually this is the
norm in u.s history that the united
states military has been fighting in
almost every year of u.s history
since independence um all but 11 years
the united states military has been
involved in some kind of a war or other
form of combat and
i put simply i we we need to stop
fighting uh this the fighting this
really endless forever war that we've
been fighting has not only
damaged and taken the lives of millions
of people around the world it's been in
ways that i think are often invisible to
us harming the vast majority of people
in the united states in profound ways
did you say we've we've been at war with
somebody from inception 1776 till today
except for 11 years
that's great that's right and that's
based on a list that the congressional
research service puts together
um and which i've updated uh with the
help of others
uh yeah um
what were those 11 years
uh there were a few years at the end of
the 19th century a few years during the
the roosevelt administration when he
uh in addition to the the new deal
brought into effect what he called the
good neighbor policy where he ended a
long pattern of invading latin american
countries in particular a few years in
the the late 1970s um but you know by
some accounts the united states has
never been at peace there are other
you know cia interventions um coups um
other forms of of warfare that the
united states has been engaged in
arguably in every year since
independence and this is not a
democratic or republican thing it's just
our leaders like to go to war they just
so do you think it's because
uh uh our nature from day one when we
fought away you know from our
independence from britain it was kind of
like in our nature to constantly
be in that fight mode that that's just
in our genes in the dna in the fabric of
what america was founded on or do you
think some of it is like we're causing
it and it's self-inflicted
i think it's definitely self-inflicted i
think uh it is deeply rooted in u.s
history but it's definitely not in our
genes or our dna
or in some sort of inherent u.s american
character i think
there are patterns that were were
created uh and actually that predate the
creation of the united states the
history i tell in the united states of
war goes back before uh the creation of
the united states and shows how the
united states emerged out of european
empires that colonized the the western
hemisphere the americas um specifically
and most importantly the us of course
emerges out of the british empire gains
its independence from britain but models
itself us
leaders model the united states after
the european empires and then they
attempted to build a an expansionist
empire that uh came to conquer
territories across north america and
this put into into place a system of
permanent or almost permanent war it's
important to point out that that no war
was inevitable no war is inevitable um
this is not a pattern that has to
continue forever and that's why i you
know again that's why
what you just said you said no war is
inevitable and no war can be avoided
uh no war is inevitable and um no in
indeed we can avoid future wars and
that's why i wrote the book because i
think we need to choose a different path
uh u.s leaders have avoided wars in the
past often because large groups of
people pressured them not to go to war
including sometimes members of the us
military
uh and we need to choose a path like i
said before we need to stop fighting we
need to break this this pattern um and i
believe we can do it uh but we need to
we need to choose a fundamentally
different course for this country yeah
i'm looking at the stats right now when
you said this so my mind went to budget
right okay so 2020 our budget was
778 billion dollars
and we're at the top that's statista the
website right number two is china
252 billion which is about a third then
we got india's only 72 billion which is
uh less than a tenth
and you have russia 61 billion the 12th
uk 59 billion saudi 57 billion germany
53 billion and france japan south korea
italy australia canada israel brazil at
20 billion right and we're at 778.
um minimum minimum that's a minimum yeah
and again whatever statistic not a left
or right wing
it's like a gallop you kind of try it's
like pure research it's not uh it's not
the times it's not the wall street
journal it's not fox or cnn it's pretty
relatively just giving you stats there
yeah
so
so based on some of the stuff they said
out of all the wars like you know
sometimes
when you're raising your kids you try to
do your like the other day my son got
into a big fight with a kid in school
pretty bad fight nine year old
so i sat down and i went and sat down
with spoke with them and i'm the guy
that one of the affirmations we have
with our kids is one we don't bully and
two we don't get bullied you need to
stand up for yourself so and our kids go
to
conservative schools so you know it's
like well we don't fight we don't do
this and so everything is like we love
each other
but uh so i'm also the guy that will say
that guy did that to you three times if
you don't stand up for yourself you're
gonna get video games for a month you
better stand up for yourself because the
last thing i want my kids to be is a
bully
and then
so he got into a fight bad fight comes
back scratches on his back not looking
good everyone's concerned he doesn't
want to tell us what happened finally i
told him what happened so he told me
what happened i said
buddy what you just did this one's your
fault
don't you think he says no daddy this
one's my fault
i said so you call that kid that word
that's a pretty painful word he says no
i know daddy i said tomorrow i want you
to go apologize to this kid
he said you want me to apologize and
this is not a kid that apologies it's
not easy for him to say i'm sorry he's
the guy that's very proud so
so he goes the next day and he
apologizes i said what happened he says
because i told him i said if you
apologize if he continues to bully you
you got to hit him in the face okay
but if you apologize to him and he
forgives you
then you guys are going to become better
i said there's a 99 chance he's going to
leave you alone and you guys will be
friends he goes to school tells the kid
i'm sorry
next thing you know he says we're best
friends now so fantastic great so we as
parents want our kids to avoid as many
fights as possible you don't want to go
to a bar and start a fight with anybody
you know you do it to the wrong person
you can have a nose looking like mine
it's not a good idea it's not a good
look
so
here's the point
how many of these wars that we had based
on your research based on your opinion
how many of them could we have avoided
that i don't think it's possible we
could have avoided all of them but which
one of them based on your opinion and
research could we have avoided
i think almost all of them uh first of
all i hope your son is okay i'm sorry to
hear about about his fight
he's actually doing great thanks for
asking though good good um no i think
it's important to point out that the the
vast majority of u.s wars have been
offensive wars of choice
when japan attacked pearl harbor and
other parts of the united states in 1941
this is the exception in u.s history
defensive wars are are not part of our
history offensive wars like the wars the
united states has launched since 2001
are the pattern are the norm
um and so i i think the united states
could have and it needs to
make the avoidance of war
its foreign policy needs to make peace
building its foreign policy rather than
assuming that there will be future wars
which i think far too many leaders you
civilian leaders military leaders assume
they assume that the united states will
be fighting in perpetuity and that's in
my mind truly truly frightening and
that's a big part of the problem
you could have avoided all of them you
think we could have avoided all the wars
that we had
again i think the vast majority um you
know if you look at the list and i mean
maybe it's
i've heard it's it's helpful to let me
just read a sample of the countries that
the united states has invaded and gone
to war with in in us history just start
with our neighbors mexico us has gone to
war with or invaded mexico 10 times
canada 11 times uh panama 24 times uh
peru the seminole
the cherokee delaware greece meaning the
country of greece
apache turkey
hawaii of course nicaragua samoa the
philippines china honduras haiti vietnam
cambodia laos afghanistan colombia libya
niger yemen iraq kenya syria
and the list goes on and on 135
countries at least
where the united states has gone to war
um again in 234 out of the 235 years in
u.s history
these have been wars of choice often
wars of expansion often wars to protect
economic interests to advance the
economic interests of elites or or
businesses uh and these are wars that by
and large have not benefited the vast
majority of people in the united states
yeah i mean i would you agree that most
people are are for avoiding wars on all
pilots on all political lands would you
say most people if they could have
avoided a war they'd want to
in a certain sense yes i think i think i
think that is something we can virtually
all agree on
um but the actions of so many u.s
leaders uh seem again
to assume that the united states will
will continue to go to war and will will
fight uh
essentially a forever war as people
often refer to it now
and and the choices us leaders have made
beginning with the budget and it's
really important that you pointed to the
budget the us military budget is at
least as large as the next 11 countries
combined
including china as you pointed out but
most of those 11 countries are actually
u.s allies um these are not enemies
the choices that u.s leaders have made
about
beginning with with the u.s military
budget has actually made it more likely
that the united states would go to war
and one of the major arguments would i
show in in my book
the united states of war is that in
addition to these huge military budgets
the pattern of building u.s military
bases abroad the pattern of building u.s
military bases on other people's
territory
outside the united states has actually
made it more likely the united states
would go to war and this is a
long-standing pattern that dates to
independence
but but especially now where the united
states
has around
750 military bases outside the 50 states
in washington dc this is a permanent
infrastructure 70 plus countries by the
way so that's exactly this is a
permanent infrastructure of war that is
making it more likely we're going to
wage more wars
yeah i don't disagree there because if
you think about that so let's just say
we have 700 to 800 in 70 plus countries
have you done the research on how many
uh bases china has outside of china
i have i have yeah and it is again a
good comparison
china has one base in djibouti one
foreign military base in djibouti it has
five other bases on human-made islands
in the south china sea you could count
bases in tibet as well but a tiny
handful of bases compared to this
collection of 750 to 800
bases abroad that the united states has
maintained and we've had even more in
the past
and djibouti is is the uh
choke point it's uh you know they're
trying to protect the let's just say oil
because they rely seventy percent their
oil they get it from there so
that kind of makes sense let's just say
they want to protect themselves but
of the 750 bases that we have okay
that's kind of like renting a bedroom
from
you know
750 other families and living in their
house to see what they're up to so as
their wife could as a husband kids are
good everybody's good okay good okay
guys i'm just watching you guys you know
it essentially it's kind of like that
you know now obviously some places we
offer protection but
if we were to do you actually know the
budget i'm assuming you would probably
know the number on this how much does it
cost us to keep those 750 bases active
in those 80 plus countries
another great question yeah
as of my last estimate around 51 billion
dollars a year
51 billion dollars a year this is a huge
budget it rivals that of the state
department
and is larger than the budget of almost
any
government agency other than the
pentagon itself and the veterans
administration
and this again shows you the priorities
that u.s leaders have put into place
and again that's part of what needs to
change
why do we do that why why are we
everywhere are we
the mother are we the you know daddy
we're looking out for everybody are we
are they asking us are some of the
country safer because we're there why do
you think we're in so many different
places
well
in short i think the united states is
not safer and the world is not safer
because there are 750 bases around the
world uh i think in in a whole variety
of ways and and there are people across
the political spectrum who who agree
with me these bases are actually
undermining u.s security
most of these bases
date to around world war ii and the
early days of the cold war and in many
ways once they've been established
they've been extremely difficult to
close
we have not decided to put these bases
around the world us a small group of u.s
leaders mostly white male
elite dudes like me
who work in the u.s government have
decided
uh to put these bases around the world
and in a whole variety of ways we could
be protecting ourselves
much more effectively we could be
spending our military dollars more
effectively positioning our military
more effectively
and we could be protecting ourselves
against the real threats that face the
united states beginning with well i
don't know uh pandemic preparedness
if we think you know if we just taken a
portion of that 51 billion dollars a
year we spend on military bases abroad
just
maintaining them
uh if we'd spent a portion of that to
prepare for pandemics uh to build
adequate supplies of ppe uh to provide
universal health care we
just imagine how many hundreds of
thousands of lives we could have saved
just in the cobit pandemic alone
you know uh
that sounds noble when you say that
and in every part of my body i go to
okay
i get it i want to be noble as well that
makes sense to me but then you hear the
troops hey we're going to pull the
troops from afghanistan the withdrawal
you remember this when it was in april
they were talking about it
and both hillary clinton and condoleezza
rice on opposing ends neither one of
them supported it they said that's not a
good move to make
and we should stay there because if we
pull out things could get pretty ugly
you know could be
you know more war more you know others
could take over and we're going to
empower those guys
somebody may say well david i i i'm all
for your noble causes
but if we pull troops out of all these
different places
and say everybody has to solve their own
problems themselves and a full-on war
breaks out proxy wars manipulative wars
does that affect us at all
and if it doesn't
okay in what ways do you think it
doesn't affect us but if it does should
we just stay there
so first of all i i think you know
hillary clinton and condoleezza rice
should have very little credibility when
it comes to speaking on matters of
foreign policy these are the architects
of the last 20 years of war these are
some of the architects of the
wars in afghanistan and iraq and for
example libya which is uh turned into a
terrible proxy war and uh
uh you know a dissolved state
effectively in in libya that where
hillary clinton was the the leading
light in in
launching that war
um
the the fact is we are in a state of of
warfare
in many parts of the globe uh wars that
often the united states military has
launched or gotten deeply involved in uh
in as well as proxy wars uh and
continuing with the status quo is just
going to continue
these wars the united states needs to
shift its emphasis from warfare to
diplomacy to trying to end these wars
diplomatically uh you know
yes
afghanistan looks terrible right now but
the solution was not to just keep
the united states military in
afghanistan in perpetuity
which is essentially what we've been
well what u.s leaders have been doing
for the last 20 years another path needs
to be pursued and i'm glad that by the
administration announced the withdrawal
of most not all u.s troops from
afghanistan
but it needs to go much farther to try
to reduce
and minimize the violence and damage
that is going on there as well as in the
other war zones where the united states
should rapidly remove itself the two
eras you said when the 11 years that we
didn't have war
you
you said the fdr was one of them i'm
assuming you were talking about fdr the
new uh
so you were talking about him and then
late 70s i'm assuming you're talking
about carter were you referencing carter
okay so carter so do you think carter
who
i write about him in a book
his his campaign was what it was human
rights right it was all about human
rights human rights human rights and it
was looking at two main countries right
one of them was iran one was cuban
uh extremely uh i don't think there are
many people that would
call this man a bad man
he was a sweet man smart man intelligent
man but history says he wasn't the best
president we ever had he's typically on
the bottom list the best presidents we
had not in the top ftr different story
you'll hear a lot of liberals will say
fdr's maybe the greatest president we've
had in the last hundred some years and
many a great arguments for it some will
say no he changed the game he brought
taxes he brought this you brought that
fine but we've seen the fdr side do you
think carter
did a good job with this presidency and
if yes which parts of it
it's a good question well avoiding war
avoiding the launching of of new wars i
think was uh absolutely an effective
part of his presidency and if we just
look at you know a death count um i
think the united states inflicted less
damage on the war
on the excuse me less damage through war
on the world than under other presidents
including
ronald reagan who followed president
carter or presidents ford and nixon
who of course helped
you know especially nixon and johnson
before him
beginning even earlier with uh president
kennedy is so allotted uh you know the
the disaster in vietnam
uh
took somewhere between two and three
million lives so i think just in terms
of the damage inflicted i think
president carter uh limited the damage
that the united states was
inflicting now he also was responsible
for getting the united states involved
in afghanistan the last 20 years of war
really dates in 1979
and the united states government trying
to lure
the soviet union into what it described
as the afghan trap to give them their
own vietnam and indeed they did and then
under presidents carter and reagan
the u.s proceeded to back the mujahideen
a word that people have probably been
hearing in recent days
uh or weeks um the taliban they
described themselves as mujahideen holy
warriors
um where where do they come from they
come from the cia-backed
campaign
to challenge the soviet occupation of
afghanistan in the 1980s and this i
think shows us the the kind of blowback
that that our long-standing policy has
has
has sown um and i think it shows how
counterproductive the long-standing
foreign policy of the united states has
been that it has often created new
enemies uh that the wars and proxy wars
that you mentioned before had actually
created more militants created more
people who would use
terrorist acts against the united states
and and u.s allies
this policy has really done very little
other than to ensure the perpetuation of
permanent war
yeah so uh
you know when i look at uh carter carter
directly affected my life so for example
i'm an october 1878 baby
october 1878 is the peak of iran
revolution it's when cinema wrecks fire
happened in abaddon iran right
and khomeini through his tapes has
gotten millions of people in iran that
have been listening to this tape he's
sending his tapes from
paris france when he was in exile there
for many years
and gradually they're starting to turn
against the shah right now
uh carter who went there december 31st
of 1977
and he had a toast with the shaw
and you know he says uh you know the
middle east is a safer place because the
shower relationship is great you just
kind of build up the show and it was
very interesting
and then leaves when deshawn needed help
kissinger and carter didn't support
they're like no leave them alone let
them do their own thing so he kind of
followed your playbook it's saying well
guys these guys got to figure out on
their own you know we can't send more
troops we can't help them out
and then let them handle their own
problems so okay
uh well the shock was in exile okay
khomeini comes and takes over
khomeini comes in and takes over
all those political prisoners that the
shah had the 3 000 of them carter asked
them to release them he released them
many of them are the today's communists
and today's
uh uh what do you call it uh al qaeda
many of them are
isis who were there and a lot of the
folks who had those ideas we had him in
prison but carter wanted to release him
he releases them the next 10 years half
a million lives now that's just not half
a million lives in iran but you're
talking us iran many other people and he
did the same thing with cuba
and cuba released 125 000 political
prisoners that came to miami on that
muriel boat lift and the unemployment in
miami went to 50 for 12 months there was
no gas during that time gas shortages
miami in the early 80s was not a place
to be it was an ugly place to be but
these were noble causes that carter had
so sometimes for me
this is the feeling i get and and i
don't know who's right and who's not
right so a kid goes through a challenge
so my position may be stand up for
yourself but a mother may say baby you
don't need to fight if you don't need to
fight who's right i think they're both
right
but sometimes you're going to make the
wrong decision
you know in some positions you do need
to stand up for yourself in some
position you do need to let it go some
people if you don't stand up for
yourself they're going to keep bullying
you and they're going to come and take
everything you have
in some positions if you
you know
you could have the opportunity to not
even cost anybody's life you could have
just been like listen let's figure this
out let's go in the room and talk for a
few hours until we can negotiate
something let's just not go to work
because people's lives are going to be
lost do you think there's a little bit
of that
contradiction where if somebody hasn't
been in the room to see how ugly war is
that there's actually bad people that
want to kill you and your people there
is actually bad people that will do
anything to make your life a living kill
and if you don't stand up to them it's
like what reagan said we don't negotiate
with terrorists they're gonna come and
take everything you got from you if they
could so do you think there's a little
bit of that contradiction in there where
if you're too soft and you think it
looks good long term you're gonna cost
it could end up costing you a lot of
lives
no i i think i mean there are a few
things i would i would wonder about that
and would want to see the evidence that
the people released by the shah in the
1970s became isis or became al-qaeda uh
i would want to see that evidence and
similarly my understanding of the cuban
migration to miami is that actually the
miami
economy was able to absorb large numbers
of of
refugees people fleeing cuba because
essentially the more people who migrated
actually created new economic
opportunities but that that's not the
core of your question
or your question and i think in a way i
would i would turn it back on you is to
ask you know who who is bullying the
united states and more importantly who
is it really a threat to the united
states i i think one of the
long-standing problems we've seen since
the 1970s and really throughout the cold
war but to this day is a kind of
fear-mongering about others a kind of
inflation of the threat of others the
soviet union was another empire like the
united states and did pose something of
a threat but its threat was consistently
exaggerated by us leaders especially u.s
leaders who wanted
to inflate the size of military budgets
uh let alone you know a small group of
militants in in the middle east which uh
whether al qaeda or another group um
they do not pose uh
any kind of existential threat to the
united states and inflating the threat
of others is really a dangerous uh
strategy
that uh has has really um only created
more trouble uh and and more war
over time
so you don't think they uh
pose any threat to the united states
who who in particular the isis or
al-qaeda
i think they pose a very limited threat
to the united states i think they pose a
greater threat to the united states
today than they did in 2001 i mean what
is the
the last 20 years of war have had many
effects 15 000 us military personnel
dead that's that's uniform personnel and
contractors um hundreds of thousands
coming back with ptsd traumatic brain
injuries
the death toll in in the war zones has
been far far worse three to four million
people likely dead in afghanistan iraq
pakistan
uh yemen
uh syria uh in the part of the war the
united states has been involved in um
tens of thousands tens of millions
injured in these war zones and seven
trillion dollars seven trillion dollars
that the united states has spent on
these wars in the last 20 years what has
it produced in addition to all that
death and suffering and what we didn't
spend seven trillion dollars on there
are more militant groups now than there
were in 2001. this war has on its own in
its own terms been a complete and utter
catastrophe and disaster
and i don't i don't think people i mean
we you know we went back to the 70s and
in vietnam i don't think people see the
last 20 years of war
in the same way they saw vietnam as a
the disaster that it was the last 20
years of war has been at least as
disastrous at least as catastrophic for
the united states for the world as the
u.s wars in vietnam and southeast asia
and i think we have to recognize that
because indeed i think there are greater
threats to the united states today than
there were in 2001 but i think they are
still very minimal we're talking about a
small group of people isis controls
almost no territory now
um and al-qaeda is is a
fraction of what it once was
um so i i think it's really dangerous to
over inflate the problems and to respond
to these problems with war that that was
the first mistake the bush
administration made
the attacks of 911 took about 3 000
lives terrible for the the people
affected for the families affected
absolutely
the united states the bush
administration did not need to respond
to that those crimes with war
by invading a country that had
no i mean the vast majority of people in
afghanistan had no responsibility for
the attacks of 9 11. the taliban gave
sanctuary to al qaeda but was not
involved in planning or orchestrating
the attacks of 9 11. the united states
should have responded to those crimes of
that day september 11 2001 as crimes
responded with criminal justice
responses with criminal justice
agents
how do you do that what what
what what does these are people that are
willing to put their lives on the line
to take
to to to
make show your weakness these are people
that you that's a achievement if you do
that to them how are you going to get to
the people that did what they did to to
us
no that's
indeed i think that the problem was that
by giving them the war they wanted that
was an achievement for them
in the past u.s
governments have responded to terrorist
crimes
as crimes and research shows beyond the
u.s around the world
that responding with warfare
tends not to be a very effective
response to terrorist acts uh that
responding with diplomacy with
intelligence gathering with criminal
justice responses
is far more effective than war
by giving al-qaeda and osama bin laden a
war it gave them exactly what they
wanted in a much larger platform for
recruiting
for building their movement
and i think the past 20 years shows how
what a disastrous choice that was
yeah i mean listen osama bin laden
bragged about the fact that he made
america spend three trillion dollars to
kill them i mean the guy's life was
worth three trillion dollars that's a
lot of money for one guy so in reality
he won because he depleted america's
bank account there's no question about
that but
and we should think about what you know
the three trillion winners i don't
disagree with you i totally agree with
you yeah but there's a part of that
that's also america's uh
uh uh foundation uh you know how america
was founded like look at the movie
saving private ryan so i'm from 100
airborne division that we want saving
private ryan before the world wants to
save in private iran because it was our
unit so they brought us in a auditorium
600 soldiers we watched like oh my gosh
this is my unit we're all crying i do
anything for my country
but then afterwards there was a debate
why sacrifice you know eight nine ten
people's lives
for a private just because he's the only
one that's left in a family why do we do
that what was that all about that's not
worth it why take those guys live just
because they have other siblings
and that's a real debate by the way
somebody can sit there and say
you kind of do make a point here but no
you because this family cannot continue
and that mom and dad sacrifice their two
sons that went there one is no longer
around one of them is we gotta go save
this private ryan kid
so it's a great discourse when it goes
back and forth but that's you know what
we were founded on that's america's
foundation so part of this is
you attack our land
and you want me to sit there and not do
anything about it
and and okay if i send crime like from
treat them as criminals
oh my gosh i mean that's uh uh that's uh
exactly what they're looking for because
you know
one guy
was talking about there was these debate
taking place on war between a america
and middle east it was a strong debate
and one fellow said you know why uh
you know uh al-qaeda isis these guys are
not afraid of uh us they said why he
says because america's culture is very
forgiving
we're not forgiven we're gonna venge
we're gonna come after you and we're
gonna get you for what you did for us so
meaning
let's just say today we start becoming
noble as a country okay
you all of a sudden decide to become a
noble nation hypothetically we become a
noble nation today guys we're going to
be noble pull everybody out 750 units
we're coming on we're going to save that
51 billion dollars we don't need to be
invading we're all back home let's put
the money in a different place we don't
need to do this anymore fine
we bring the budget down from 770
billion to say 150 let's match china 250
billion we save ourselves a half a
trillion dollars fine
how many enemies have we killed
how many people are you know preparing
their vengeance against us you think
they've forgotten
you you think they've forgotten how many
kids lives were taken
you you think there's people there that
lost a brother a daughter
a a wife
a family member that's you a father
that's a six-year-old kid that's now 22
years old for 16 years all he's been
thinking about is america is the enemy
i'm gonna get you i know people like i
lived around these types of people when
i was in iran for 10 years
you can say listen we don't want to
fight anymore we're so sorry
we're going to play the noble card right
now dude i don't care what you're gonna
do you kill my dad i'm gonna do whatever
i can to ruin your life
so part of me wants to say david
noble there's another part of me that
says aren't we in too deep to play nice
now
i think you know i think with the the
uh
picture your your painting
is one that is a recipe for
perpetual war forever
that
yes we need to protect ourselves under
any
circumstances we need to have a us
military
it should be focused on protecting u.s
citizens and protecting the borders of
the united states not on
creating an offensive platform for war
that has military bases around the world
and is ready to launch wars on a
moment's notice which is what we have
now
and i think what the the recipe
that you're describing is just going to
produce more people like that 16 year
old whose father was killed who wanted
uh do
violence against u.s citizens or the
united states i think we need to choose
another path
the last 20 years of war has just
created more people
who would wish to inflict harm on the
united states
both by
killing frequently assassinating
militants but frequently by taking the
lives of
innocent civilians who then have had a
grudge against the united states this
strategy that the united states has been
pursuing
has been completely counterproductive
and has really put us at more risk as
u.s citizens and as a country
and that's what needs to change
yeah there's a part of me that doesn't
disagree with that i i don't uh i won't
sit there and say listen all this
you guys did before us we're putting up
it's like all the spending all this
money you guys keep spending all these
stimulus you keep giving away thinking
it's a good thing you print 40 percent
of all the money that's been printed in
the history of america was printed last
15 months okay who the hell is going to
pay that back who's going to pay that
back i mean inflation oh it's just going
to last a few more months no it's not
you can only keep interest rates so low
for so long no matter what power is
talking about or yelling is talking
about we're going to pay a price for
this stuff is going to go up people are
going to be one day waking up saying how
am i supposed to keep up in the
marketplace so what i am saying is
if you take that position of 270
200 and how old are we 70
to whatever 245 years
of
playing the tough guy and i dare you to
do something i'm going to whoop your you
know what if you come after me and watch
what we're going to do to you watch what
if we play that role
i i i um
i think it's very hard to get away from
that and play the
amicable role because you may be the
current person that may be noble but i'm
not upset at you i'm upset at your
father i'm upset at your grandfather i'm
upset the president before you or the
four presidents before you so
how do we go about so let's have the
conversation with isis let's have the
conversation with china let's have the
conversation with these countries how do
you have that conversation with them and
be a diplomat who does it biden does it
who who does that
obama does that true you dedicate you
dedicated as much
energy
and resources
you actually don't need to dedicate as
much resources because
diplomacy is is is quite cheap complex
compared to weapon systems that often we
don't need there's just sinkholes of
literally billions of dollars um you you
dedicate money to a to to diplomacy to
the state department to
from
biden on down
a whole range of people dedicated to
resolving conflicts peacefully and
diplomatically
and and shift money away from this war
machine that we've built
otherwise we are going to just continue
and i again i i would point to
periods in u.s history when u.s leaders
have chosen different paths
again
roosevelt franklin delano roosevelt
he had this good neighbor policy while
people are talking about uh a green new
deal i think we should also bring back
roosevelt's good neighbor policy and
what were the tenets of of his good
neighborhood policy it was you know as
the name suggests um being a good
neighbor to to people in the in the
western hemisphere and around the world
it meant renouncing
armed intervention in other countries
it meant renouncing the right to
intervene in the affairs of other
countries and other peoples and i think
you know again the the sort of
portrait of the world you're
you're depicting of of
people who are aggrieved at the united
states
it is inaccurate there are
you know thousands of people like that
because of the last 20 years before and
and because
longer history but but those you know
individuals
grieved against the united states that
is not a
threat and that should not be the basis
for our foreign policy are you kidding
me are you come on david we can't be
naive i mean you know do we need a
thousand people you've written a lot
about the holocaust haven't you you've
been writing about holocaust for a long
time
right i mean i've seen articles about uh
from what you've written about the
holocaust
so for you let's just say about
your family was directly impacted by it
no by the holocaust yeah okay
so
how many
hitlers do you need
you don't need thousands you only need
one
that is dedicated
to
his vengeance
and that cost millions of people's life
so you know they asked fidel if you
wanted to create your revolution again
how many thousands of believers would
need
he said i would only need one other true
believer who believes in a hundred
percent of what i want to do i would
still do the same exact thing i did
right now so the hitler so
it doesn't take thousands of people who
are upset at america
it just takes a handful of people that
are such true believers that if they
want to retaliate
911 is a circus act compared to what
they can do next
uh on the kind of eventually again
and i think we need to be really careful
about
our our assessment of threat and our
assessment of risk
uh you know hitler was a risk because he
was the most powerful person then led
a
very large country that had a very large
and powerful economy
and a military force that that he built
up
that is a threat
that is that is a legitimate threat but
an individual with crazy beliefs on it
on
their own is not a threat not a threat
that needs to be taken seriously at the
level of
designing our foreign policy around um
so that that i think we need to be
really careful in assessing threats and
be careful about exaggerating the
threats posed by by other individuals or
even groups of people um because
by inflating threats that
really aren't don't pose the risk uh
that some people might say
we
tend to
invest money in
again in our military and warfare uh
that that could be much better spent
addressing the real threats facing the
united states again
like pandemics like the the epidemic of
homelessness or hunger in this country
you know these are demonstrable problems
and and and threats or you know the
decrepit state of our public school
system these are real threats and things
that people are living with every day
and they are not being addressed when
we're spending trillions of dollars on
war
you know uh uh
when you're a kid living in a country
where you watch outside the window and
you see tens of thousands of grown men
flagellating their backs with a streak
of blood on the streets and they're
screaming matic bat ombrica
you will have a different perspective of
what threat really is all about because
you personally witness it
uh when you go to germany and you live
at a refugee camp for a couple years
and you kind of see how
they view
the middle east and how iran views usa
you kind of get a different perspective
uh when when you it's kind of like
there's a couple things that i believe
in now you don't have to agree with this
but for me like i don't think
a person to become a president of the
united states
if they've never ran a small business
that they have to hire and fire people
or if they've never been in the military
i don't think you're qualified to be the
president now that's me
why why do i believe that because if
you've never been in the military how do
you know what my life looks like how do
you know what i do you're the
commander-in-chief maybe we need to
you're the president but maybe we need
to have a general that's in charge of
the military you should not have any
right so if a president ever becomes a
president who's never been in the
military you're just the president you
are required to hire somebody that runs
the military and he gives you advice but
he's the decision maker with the
military now you because you've never
been in the military before you may have
150 million followers on instagram or
twitter but you've never been in the
military the same as goes as if you've
never ran a business you don't know the
pains of putting money into business you
don't know the pains of losing your job
if you've been a lifelong politician
you're not ready to be a president and
understand what it is to be a small
business owner so for me
these types of matters
are extremely noble i would love for
your vision to become a reality
as long as
the other side doesn't give birth to the
next adolf which history tells us
it is filled
with men like that who were fully
ambitious
to go after regimes like ours and it's
very exciting and and easy to
propose some of these things while it's
pretty sick like for example i would
assume you would probably call trump a
uh peace president because of what he
did with israel and palestine something
that no other president could do for 25
years and under his presidency
i don't think we heard about isis a
single time versus the past 20 years
prior to him
all we ever heard about was isis i mean
i think under obama and bush it was isis
isis isis so you you probably in your
notion you would probably put trump in
the same level as carter and fdr would
you
no no i mean trump was a disaster in so
many ways there were a few ways
in which he
is especially when it came to foreign
policy
he took some some helpful steps um he
talked about wanting to end the endless
wars he he didn't
um but he didn't start a new war which
was an improvement um over his
predecessors president obama
and president bush um you know i would
just say you know it's it's not just
about being noble
or pursuing a foreign policy or a way of
uh engaging with the rest of the world
that's noble um this is a you know
from a self-interested perspective we
need to choose a different past
let's look at isis which you've
mentioned isis is a product of the us
war in iraq isis did not exist prior to
the us invasion and war in iraq we
created isis this is
you know the the recipe of of permanent
bullying and permanent war is only going
to create more isis it's only going to
make it more likely
that the kinds of uh
you know leaders that you're
you're concerned about that they might
come to come to power and have some some
following um we we need to choose a
different path unless we want to
be fighting it forever and and let me
just say another thing because
i don't want to sort of get caught in a
in a cycle of of disagreement no the
united states is an empire
united states has been an empire no it
is it is an empire yeah and it says has
been an empire virtually since
independence and shortly and after
independence it's an empire that
conquered territory across north america
conquered territories outside north
america and the years that followed
empires don't last forever
empires don't last forever and this
empire is going to come to an end sooner
or later
and
my fear is that by continuing to pursue
this path permanent war we're just
bringing about the end of our empire
more and more rapidly um we're making it
more likely that we are going to
dissolve as an empire and perhaps as a
nation
in either bankruptcy or a catastrophe
and even more catastrophic war or both
uh and that that that's the path we're
on now
we have a choice and can wind down our
empire and choose another path not just
out of nobility or for nobility's sake
but because we want to protect ourselves
we want to protect the well-being of
people in the united states and we want
to protect people around the world
rather than
harming ourselves and harming people
around the world in the profound ways
that we have for the last 20 years alone
so so david just out of curiosity so how
let's just say we we shut down the 750
let's say we're out we're back here
what do you do with uh uh reinvesting of
the money would you say we have way too
many soldiers would you cut down on the
amount of soldiers that we have in
america would you cut down on active
duty would you
uh say we don't need as many
uh active duty and navy
army air force whatever uh
that we have do we go much lower what do
we do with that money
yeah so
well first of all i think there we
should have a conversation about the
appropriate
size of the us military especially after
withdrawing from afghanistan and and
as my hope is as we withdraw
ourselves from and end the other endless
wars
um but in in the short term we can close
spaces abroad and bring troops and
family members remember there are
hundreds of thousands of family members
abroad as well
bringing them back to the united states
where they would benefit local economies
bringing troops back from afghanistan
and from germany and
from italy from
south korea from japan bringing them
back to florida bringing them back to
california bringing them back to texas
actually benefits those local economies
and there is
excess
infrastructure in the united states to
accommodate them
we take money saved by closing bases
abroad i think first and foremost we
have to look at needs that have been
neglected for far too long again
beginning with pandemic preparedness
with health health care with
ending homelessness in this country
ending hunger in this country improving
our public school system
providing opportunity more opportunities
for people to go to college
at the same time we can be spending
money on the military in far wiser ways
both in terms of where we invest in
infrastructure
and in the investments we make in
weaponry i mean we're you know
f-35 this complete boondoggle that's
created a plane that mostly can't fly
can't engage in con in combat
but has cost billions and billions of
dollars that mostly has gone into the
pockets of lockheed martin this is just
a symbol of the problem that is the
military industrial complex or military
industrial congressional complexes as
eisenhower initially called it um it
hasn't been part of the conversation but
part of the reason we are trapped in
this system of permanent war in this
sort of warfare state is because
since world war ii in particular
us leaders have created
and fed a military industrial
congressional complex that has led us
astray that has led us down a path of
permanent war that has benefited the
the weapons manufacturers and and kept
them nice and happy while uh neglecting
human needs that are so
painfully felt by so many people in this
country
and i want to i want to believe what
you're thinking is possible i want to
believe what you're thinking is possible
because
my my
well let me ask you a different question
uh what do you think about with the way
some of our who would you say america's
number one enemy is today i'm curious
out of your research in the military if
you're saying our top three enemies
today not even enemies concerns let's
call them concerns not direct enemies
number one country would be this number
two would be this number three would be
this what would you say this
yeah
one is one that i haven't mentioned yet
global warming climate change two i
would say is is is health health the the
awful state of health in our country and
number three would probably be education
um i i don't i don't think we should be
thinking about the world as
as as filled with enemies the vast
majority i mean yes there are leaders of
other countries who engage in horrific
and terrible acts
we should we should condemn them but the
vast majority of people in for example
uh
iran or
china or north korea have nothing to do
with the actions of their
or or decisions of their their their
leaders um they are not you know
1.3 billion people in china they're not
my enemy
are there
are there leaders in the communist party
who are responsible for terrible human
rights abuses uh and other horrific acts
yes um and i i don't i don't like them
um similarly i don't like u.s leaders
who have been responsible for
millions of deaths
tens of millions of i agree i totally
agree with you
like you know you're right so for
example a governor cuomo right okay all
those lives that were lost in new york
uh in the nursing home so you're right
so he does that and let's just say uh
new york says everybody has to be
vaccinated or else you can't have the
keys to new york de blasio says that
right okay
fine so but that's not new york that's
the governor of new york that's imposing
those laws right you know
mayor viagrossa says if you see anybody
in the streets during the pandemic we're
going to give it 200 if you can tell us
who's out there
okay i may not run it that way but
that's how he runs it i don't think the
people of la are bad
but i think cuomo made bad decisions i
think via grosso made bad decisions you
can look at different governors that
made bad decisions in different states i
don't say you know florida's bad texas
bad illinois is bad california's bad new
york is bad it's the leaders at the top
that are making the decisions one
doesn't have save for what de blasio is
going to do if de blasio says that if
you disagree with him you can't say
anything about it those are the rules
that he's uh
selling to the people but what i'm
asking you is
which countries do you see as us's
enemies not the people who live in that
country but the leaders who run those
countries which ones concern you
again i i think i am a little cautious
of this framing of enemies because so
often this has been used
to
to demonize not just leaders but entire
populations i mean this is part of why
part of why we've seen growing
anti-asian anti-asian-american
sentiment in this country
because of the demonization of china
writ large people don't say the chinese
communist party rarely or the chinese
government they tend to just say china
and then we tend to think of the entire
country as our enemy this is what
happened during the cold war people i
grew up thinking that russians were my
enemy and they weren't my enemy there
were soviet leaders and like u.s leaders
who were responsible for fueling the
cold war you don't think it's exciting
to know which personalities we have to
look out for like
absolutely but i think we should be we
need to be really specific about what's
your favorite give the name don't get
the country just give the name like who
are top three influential
world leaders you worry about outside of
america
yeah i think that the
chinese government is is obviously the
the next most powerful government in the
world so so there are things to be
concerned about about the
chinese government similarly the russian
government
powerful but pale
both
governments both countries they pale in
comparison to the power of the soviet
union during the cold war it's important
to point out people again are are
creating china as a whole into a threat
that that it does not represent it does
not have the military power that the
soviet union had it is not a global
military power the way the soviet union
was it does not oppose
h-a-d had like past tense that's right
that's right um because soviet union
dissolved you know 30 years ago
yep um russia similarly has nothing the
other than nuclear weapons it does not
represent
anything like the threat that the soviet
union
uh
posed and again that's part of why i'm
concerned about the framing of enemies
because again it
tends to encourage people to sort of
turn their their brains off i fear um to
just sort of think with fear clouding
their minds rather than thinking about
okay let's assess the relative threat
that this country and its military for
example or other parts of its its
government like cyber it's cyber threat
what threat does it actually pose to us
and how can we protect ourselves and how
can we respond
i think
you know so much of our foreign policy
is is is is guided by by fear and often
fear-mongering the exaggeration of
threat
um rather than a careful analysis of
what threats are
are
out there in the world and and putting
them into a larger spectrum of threats
that include threats like global warming
um they're distracting us from
addressing threats like global warming
that that are are truly existential
threats that
as a world we need to we need to work
with china we need to work with china
and russia and other governments around
the world to address the threats that
are facing all of us otherwise all this
fear-mongering is just going to lead to
more war more conflict more tension that
distracts us from addressing the real
threats the real problems that are
facing all of us
how do you do that if we don't uh
lead and govern by the same values and
principles i mean you would agree that
you you don't support the way the ccp
governs their people right
correct okay so you know for them
they're more about controlling their
populace we're more about freedom of
speech we're more about free press we're
more about look we can sit there and
argue all we can there's a there's a
business model for making fun of
presidents in america i mean let's face
it it's just
comedians do better if the president is
more funny you know if it's easier to
make fun of them you can become famous
if you can make fun of the president
you do that in china you you can have a
very short lifespan if you do that but
it to me the basis of negotiation is
based on you and i sharing common values
and principles
if you and i share common values and
principles we can negotiate
if you and i don't share common values
and principles it's mathematically
impossible to negotiate because for
example
um here's one of the concerns i have
with america versus china okay
uh and i'm curious to know what you say
about this i actually i'm actually
really curious what you say about this
so
david are you by any chance mary i am i
don't know if you are married or not
i'm not okay i'm married so i'm married
and i have four kids right i got a 975
and i just had a new one five weeks ago
newborn okay so our family is very busy
and it's loud
thank you it's loud that's crazy and
good luck with sleep last time we had
sleep was a decade ago but
so
my wife and i we get into fights
many fights
husband and wife you're going to get
into a lot of fights arguments
i can't only imagine what would happen
to my personal life if my wife and i
fought and we had facebook live on the
entire time it'd be very entertaining
it'd get millions of views
it would be pretty intense it would be a
nice show if it wasn't like one of these
truman shows and it's not an act but a
real like i got facebook live everywhere
you see all the fights if a person
wanted to come in between my wife and i
to help uh cause a divorce it'd be very
easy because you know all our laundry
dirty laundry because you see all our
fights on a facebook
live every one of them you've seen on a
facebook live so you'll know how to poke
me you'll know how to poke her if you're
a girl you're trying to get me to be
like well remember that one time your
wife said this i would never do that to
you you would never do that to me no you
know vice versa you understand what i'm
saying here like if a person really
wanted to come in between us
i think america fights
politicians they fight on a facebook
live
our dirty laundry is out everybody knows
about it when's the last time you saw
china's politicians fight on a facebook
live
you don't know any of their fights and
their bickering because they do behind
closed doors
if we wanted to negotiate with a country
like china
they will not let facebook in they would
not let twitter in they will not get
youtube youtube in they would not let
any of those social media platforms in
there because god forbid if we really
find out what's going on in china
they're about censoring they're about
silencing they're about dictating
they're not about giving you the freedom
so
don't you think that makes it difficult
for a country to negotiate with another
another country that doesn't
believe in the same values and
principles that you follow
it makes it difficult
but i think unfortunately many of the
patterns you're identifying the behavior
of the chinese communist party
are patterns and practices that are
not so uncommon
in the united states i mean
the nsa has been spying on us
we came to know this
um there is a large surveillance state
in the
let alone i mean facebook we know has
been spying on us um our corporations
spy on us um we live in a surveillance
society here in the united states so so
we shouldn't
fool ourselves that you know
do we live in china no there are
freedoms that we enjoy
um but we should we should be careful
similarly you know some of the the
values
that the united states
u.s leaders have
clearly embraced values like invading
other countries are values that that the
chinese communist party has avoided
when was the last time the chinese
communist party waged a war outside its
borders
1979.
last war china was involved in outside
its borders was 1979 for one month with
vietnam one month
chinese communist party has pursued a
different policy
that has focused on building up its
economic strengths
seems like it's been pretty effective
meanwhile the united states has been
squandering
literally trillions of dollars on wars
that have only created more danger for
the united states that have diverted
money from addressing the real needs we
we face
and just to get back to your question of
diplomacy we can't choose who we
negotiate with we can't choose the
people on the other side of the
diplomatic table
we have to engage with other countries
other leaders where they are
and that is a complicated
task
but
we have to
we have to embrace diplomacy we have to
choose another path to avoid this
again as i've said this pattern of
permanent perpetual war that is only
harming ourselves and harming people
around the world
did you hear uh uh uh the the
president xi's message at their hundred
years celebrating the ccp did you hear
his message what he said i did
what you think about it pretty
motivational speech
motivational um
you know
chinese leaders like other other leaders
like u.s leaders
tend to
[Music]
exaggerate the threats of others um for
their own domestic political benefit um
and they tend to
engage in you know especially male
leaders i have to say there's another
dimension we haven't talked about a lot
of this conversation is shaped by by
gender and male posturing by male
leaders
um and i think that's a lot of what he
was engaged in president trump obviously
was was very good at you know trying to
show how how big a man he was
um and i think this is this is part of
the problem male leader is trying to to
prove their manliness
um
again we shouldn't
just we shouldn't
uh take the words of a leader and turn
it into a threat that it isn't that it
doesn't represent the chinese military
again as you you mentioned earlier uh
the united states military budget is
at least three times the size of the
chinese military budget the chinese
military is nothing of the threat again
the soviet union was its capabilities
are do not
come close to rivaling that of the
united states in in so many respects
including nuclear
chinese military is a very small nuclear
threat
um so
you know i i think we need to be really
careful about the kind of fear-mongering
that's going on about china in
particular
and one of the i think
the top of our list of foreign policy
priorities has to be the avoidance of
war with china
i think there are far too many people in
the united states who are inflating the
threat of china which is creating a kind
of self-fulfilling prophecy it runs the
risk of creating a self-fulfilling
prophecy
how would how would u.s leaders respond
if china started building
dozens of military bases near us borders
the united states military surrounds
china's borders with
literally hundreds of military bases
and has been building up its presence in
east asia in the western pacific how
would how would u.s leaders respond if
the shoe was on the other foot there
would be a call for a massive military
build up
our inflation of china of the chinese
threat is leading to an aggressive
military posture
vis-a-vis china which is only
encouraging them to spend more on their
military
in an escalating cycle and this you know
again runs the risk of being a
self-fulfilling prophecy and bringing
about a war between the united states
and china that really should be
incomprehensible that the two
wealthiest countries on earth the two
largest military spenders on earth the
two nuclear-armed powers that they could
engage in a war and that it wouldn't go
completely out of control i mean would
look make the catastrophe of the last
20 years of war look small we have to
avoid
this escalation of tension with china
military tension with china and other
tensions and we have to avoid war with
china at all costs i got to tell you you
come across as a very sweet man very i
can use the word sweet okay i'm being
serious when's your birthday about it
when is your birthday um november
november 25th
so you're sagittarius okay got it so i'm
october 18. so
yeah uh i listen
i uh uh you you sound like the type of
person i love you to be at the house you
know have dinner have a glass of wine i
think we'd have a fascinating
conversation but
there's a part of me that thinks you
know and andy grove one time wrote a
book in the 80s or 90s he said only the
paranoid survive uh i think there's a
there's a bit of paranoia necessary
against our enemies the speech i was
talking about was when xi got up and he
said
only socialism can save china and only
socialism with chinese characteristics
can develop china
uh we will never allow anyone to bully
oppress or subjugate china so far it's
fine great i understand i'd want my
leader to believe that as well
and then anyone who dares to try that
will have their heads bashed bloody
against the great wall of steel forged
by over 1.4 billion chinese i mean he
went from
civil protected to straight-up gangsters
what he went to i mean at the end i'm
like the italian mob just came out at
the end
uh maybe he's a little bit of too much
of godfather but what do you think about
that was that like a noble message
no of course that's not a noble message
and that's again the kind of sort of
macho bluster and posturing and mafia
style an american president can get away
with that that is completely
how are we going to respond i mean you
can respond by escalating the language
biden or other leaders can respond by
you know responding in kind and then
that just leads to another i i agree
with that part i agree
but but you know i think we should pay
more attention to
you know what what's what's more
gangster you know a little sort of smack
talking macho smack talking or
building and maintaining literally
hundreds of military bases
near the borders of china i mean and and
you know flying uh you know
bomber missions near the borders of
china sending aircraft carriers nor near
near china's coasts
do do we see any chinese aircraft
carriers on the coast of california i
know i don't think so that that's
gangster-like behavior
and it's only encouraging the kind of
uh you know macho talk that we're seeing
what do you what do you think about the
conspiracy theory jon stewart pitched on
stephen colbert talking about the fact
that the virus could be man-made
um i i saw that that was an interesting
uh conversation because they clearly
disagreed i i think um
i i think clearly more research needs to
be
done to figure out the the
where this virus came from um but i am
i'm i was a little disturbed by john
stewart's certainty about the the origin
of
this coronavirus
especially because it has fueled
anti-asian anti-chinese sentiment um and
violence against against asian americans
in this country
i i think i'm kind of with you when when
leaders have a little too much certainty
on any topic concerns the hell out of me
like you know being that certain that
the vaccine is 100 great and not giving
you an out that's also a little bit like
too much like i
tell me like when i was in the military
i got in and i'm like okay hey guys you
guys got to take these 11 shots why your
government property okay so i took the
anthrax shot every one of those shots
you know sometimes i wonder i'm a little
bit off because the military you know
shots i took
and we were all worried that one of our
hands is going to get bigger than the
other one you know we would play these
jokes with each other what these things
are going to do obviously nothing
happened
but you know i think i'm with you on
that side i just i just hope by the way
let's just say it was something
intentional let's just say that you know
we go and we do it and say comes back
and and jon stewart is right what should
happen to china should we just look away
and say guys you guys were bad terrible
job please don't do it again what do you
think we should do well i don't think
anyone is saying that it was intentional
on the part of the chinese i mean you
know how many people have died in china
right now they're dealing with a new
surge in in infections um i i think
the the accusation is that it
accidentally escaped from this
laboratory and you know in theory that
that is possible
um
and if if it was you know
if it was because of lacks security
protocols or some sort of accident um
you know those responsible should be
you know
held responsible
and i think you know financially
responsible and and otherwise um but
right now there is no conclusive
evidence that the chinese government or
a chinese lab is responsible for this
coronavirus um but if we find it
if we find it should we put them in the
timeout room
no we should just invade them
you and i me and you we go together me
and you we dress up as gi joes and we go
out there and go up against david vine
and patrick david invade china next on
cnn
it does sound like you know one of those
comical movies um
no way again i i think we have to
we have to
choose a a different path and and i i
hope
um
maybe if if people take away nothing
from our our conversation
uh
nothing else that that you know the the
this
path that the united states that u.s
leaders have pursued for the last 20
years and really throughout u.s history
has been
catastrophic but especially in the last
20 years
and
again not for reasons of nobility
but for reasons of protecting people in
the united states and people around the
world we need to stop fighting yeah you
choose a different path i the fact that
you're having this topic i think it it
sparks a conversation and i think we
need to have that because again for me i
was blown away that we have 750 military
bases in 80 plus countries and i was
blown away that a lot of our budget is
being used in old way of going to war 40
years ago 50 years ago while in china
they're sitting out there saying look we
don't need to spend the money that
america is using why don't we teach
ourselves cyber warfare bio warfare
they're taking a completely different
route america's not america is saying
hey why don't we go you know and they're
laughing at us yeah they're of course by
the way i agree with you that i'm also
laughing at the approach u.s military is
taking on the way they're fighting today
and uh not preparing for the kind of war
that we may face 10 20 30 40 years from
now that's how we need to play rd
sometimes the biggest part
is
you know when when people in high school
know you can fight sometimes the best
part about avoiding fights is as long as
the other guy knows you can whoop his
ass that's all that matters sometimes as
long as you either they know you can
whoop their ass or they know that your
uncle your brother your cousin or your
best friend is a guy you don't want to
fight
because if you do it's going to be fine
you can avoid 99 of fights if one of
those two things is on your side
so i think what i'm saying is david i
think what i'm proposing is i think you
and i need to go become best friends
with mike tyson okay
and then just tell everybody about it on
our twitter profile says if you mess
with me my best friend is mike tyson he
will whoop your tail
yeah no and it's um it's almost like u.s
leaders have had some sort of uh
you know profound insecurity and needed
to demonstrate that military power
of course when they've done so it's been
completely counterproductive in so many
ways including you know how many wars
these united states won in the last 20
years uh zero
um you know all they've done is to
demonstrate the inadequacies of the us
military
while of course undermining our security
in in profound ways taking the lives of
you know tens of thousands of people in
the united states and and you know
millions of people in the war zones
where the u.s military has been deployed
let me just say one last thing that that
you know i'm not alone in in holding
these sorts of views there are
a growing number of people
across the political spectrum who come
to similar conclusions that we need a
profoundly different strategy it's not
just you know leftist folks like me
they're you know anti-imperialist
republicans and libertarians coming to
similar conclusions
and that's part of what encourages me
that you know these aren't just sort of
noble ideas but that there are a growing
number of people who want to see the
united states
take another path and
and that the united states can um and
really must we have to have a sense of
urgency of of transforming u.s foreign
policy and transforming uh and ending
the the the endless wars um or else i i
fear as a country and as people were
doomed
david you seem very sincere you assume
you're coming from a very good place
and you seem somebody that really wants
to make this place a better place and i
support uh that becoming a reality how
we go about doing it
uh the more the opposing sides have
debates i think the more closer we'll
get to a better resolution the more we
avoid the talk the less likely it's
going to be happening recently i just
put out something i don't know if you
saw that or not i said uh i announced a
week ago i'll give five million dollars
two and a half million dollars to
president obama two and a half million
dollars to president trump to have them
sit down together for that money goes to
any charity they want
just to get these two men in uh uh
sitting against each other for three
hours to have a conversation together on
how we can unify america again the more
we have opposing people in the room
together i think we'll make progress the
more we avoid the conflict and the
conversation the more divided will be so
once again appreciate you for coming on
and uh sharing your uh views with us and
you know i i give you some tough
questions i push back a little bit but
you were class act about it and i
respect you for that uh folks if you
haven't ordered this book i'm gonna put
the link below the united states of war
a global history of america's endless
conflicts from columbus to islamic state
that link will be below
and the name is david vine we'll also
put his link if you want to go to
twitter and let him know uh that you
watch today's interview that'll be great
as well david thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment patrick
this is so much fun um thank you for the
great questions and the time anytime
anytime take care
take care
do you agree with them do you say we get
rid of everybody we get rid of military
all the military bases should we do that
should we all
be noble working very nicely with each
other is there threats are they not
enemies i'm curious really like them but
i want to know how you what you took
away from the interview comment below
and then on top of it i got two
interviews i want you to watch if you
want insane entertainment
probably the shortest interview i've
ever done i've never had anybody curse
me out this was the first the one and
only person ever if you've never seen it
my friend lucian truscott you can see
the connection we have together in 27
minutes in a minute you'll be
entertained when you see the intro but
the other one is with elliot uh uh uh
akerman uh uh that we did an interview
with he wrote a book called 20 i think
it's 2042 or 2043 some some book 2034
some number like that but if you've
never seen it it's a fantastic book
about what the next war would look like
and who would be involved if you've not
seen that click over here to watch it
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]